SPEAKER: For this internet of things scenario,
we will take a lawn sprinkler.
We'll look at a water level monitor.
And we have a humidity monitor or a humiture monitor,
which is humidity and temperature combined.
And if we go across into the Smart City subcategory,
there is also an atmospheric pressure monitor.
Now, one more thing to add is an industrial category;
across here, a water drain.
The situation we are simulating here could
be used within industry, such as market gardens.
Or it could be public assets, public lawns.
And in all these situations, water could be
wasted if sprinklers are on when they don't need to be.
So here is a water monitor, just say this is just
for sensing moisture at this point.
That's connected, so that the sprinkler only activates when the soil is dry.
But if it can also monitor atmospheric pressure changes and humidity
and temperature, it can look at all the weather conditions
to determine whether it is necessary to activate a sprinkler.
And if I hold down Alt here and click on the lawn sprinkler,
you can see the monitor is simulating that it's a 100% moisture.
And the sprinkler should be turned off at this point.
But let's say that the water level monitor is also testing
for excessive water, such as flooding.
And rather than just not turning the sprinkler on, it will open a drain.
So let's just simulate a lot of rainfall by turning the sprinkler back on.
You can see it might sense that it's being flooded.
And the water drain connected via the internet can be opened.
And the water disappears.
This scenario shows that by connecting sensors and actuators together
via a network, which may be a wireless network in the local area
or it may be via the mobile phone 3G, 4G networks, or whatever,
if they're connected and able to communicate and change
their actions based on what they're receiving from each other.
This is an application and a use for an Internet of Things system.